The physical universe is basically it
playful.
There is no necessity for it whatsoever.
It isn't going anywhere.
That is to say it doesn't have some
destination that it ought to arrive at
that it is best understood by analogy
with music because music as an art form
is essentially playful.
We say you play the piano,
you don't work the piano.
Why music differs from say travel when
you travel you are trying to get
somewhere in music though one doesn't
make the end all the composition.
The point if that was so the best
conductors would be those who played
faster and there would be composers who
wrote of lifting people go to concert,
just hear one crashing call cause that's
the end.
Say went dancing.
You don't aim at a particular spot in
the room.
That's where you should arrive.
The whole point of the dancing of the
doubt,
but we don't see that as something
brought by our education into our
everyday conduct.
We've got a system of schooling but
gives a completely different impression.
It's all graded and what we do is we put
the child into the corridor of this raid
system.
Well,
it kind of come on Kitty,
kitty,
kitty.
Yeah.
You go to kindergarten,
you know that's a great thing because
when you finish that,
you'll get into first grade and then
come on first grade needs the second
grade and so on.
And then you'd get out of grade school,
you've got high school and it's revving
up.
The thing is coming.
Then you're going to go to college by
Jovan.
You get into graduate school and when
you're through with graduate school,
you go out to join the world.
Then you'll get into some racket where
you're selling insurance and they've got
that quota to make and you're going to
make that.
And all the time the thing is coming,
it's coming,
it's coming.
That great thing,
the success you're working.
And then when you wake up one day,
about 40 years old,
you say,
my God,
I've arrived.
I'm there.
And you don't feel very different from
what you always felt.
Okay.
What would the people who live to retire
and put those savings away and then when
they 65 they don't have any energy left
that more or less important.
And they go and in an old people's
senior citizens community,
because we've sinned,
did cheated ourselves the whole way down
the line did we thought of life by
analogy with a journey,
with a pilgrimage which had a serious
purpose at the end.
And the thing was to get to that end
success or whatever it is,
or maybe Heaven after you're dead,
but we missed the point the whole way
along.
It was a musical thing and you were
supposed to sing or to dance while the
music was being played.